in this lesson we're going to talk about
the types of numbers so the different
types of sets of numbers that there are
and the important thing to understand
here is that sometimes they're going to
mention these in the course of a problem
and they'll say you know is this
solution in this set or is this solution
in that set or they might just make a
reference to a special type of a number
and it's good to just know what these
are so let's just go through them real
quick when they talk about the natural
numbers when you think of a natural
numbers think of like how a child would
would count if you say count to 10 okay
to your
little brother little sister or niece
nephew that kind of thing
they're gonna always start with one
right they're gonna say one two three
four five like that okay they never
start with zero they never mention
negative numbers those these are like
the counting numbers okay starting with
one those are the natural numbers then
we get to the integers now the integers
these are basically round numbers you
don't see any decimals in here you don't
see any fractions they're just whole
numbers they can be positive they can be
negative they can be zero so you can see
these are what integers are okay
and then whole numbers whole numbers are
basically like the natural numbers the
counting numbers with the addition of
zero so it's one two three four five you
don't see any negative values here you
don't see any decimals or fractions
these are whole numbers zero and the
positive integers okay now rational
numbers when they mean when they say
rational is that you can write the
quantity as a ratio meaning a fraction
of an integer divided by an integer so
for example if i have .1.17
okay that can be written as 17 100. 17
is an integer right 100 is an integer
and we're writing as a ratio of two
integers another example would be square
root of
16. well square root of 16 is 4 and 4
can be written as 4 over 1 right
repeating numbers let's say 0.2
repeating that's actually
can be written as 2 over 9. so that's an
integer by an integer
now an irrational number is not a
rational number it can't be written as a
ratio of an integer
over an integer for for example square
roots that you can't simplify like
square root of 17 this comes out to a
non-repeating non-terminating decimal
another example would be something like
pi you know pi is
3.14159 it doesn't repeat and it doesn't
stop you can't write it as a ratio of an
integer over an integer or the natural
the natural number
e okay so that's 2.71 and it doesn't
repeat and doesn't terminate
so that's rational irrational now real
numbers and complex numbers
for most of your math you know learning
so far you've been working with real
numbers uh complex numbers are basically
imaginary numbers okay so it's a
combination of part real plus imaginary
and where the imaginary numbers come in
are where you're taking the square roots
of negative numbers so if you have the
square root of negative 16 that square
root of negative 1 is i the square root
of 16 is 4 and we write it as 4i so if
it's not an imaginary number it falls
into the category of a real number okay
so if you don't see any i's or square
roots of negative numbers it's real
otherwise complex numbers are
combination of part real part imaginary
and for example you could write 3 plus
2i that's a part real part of measure
that's a complex number so
this is just a quick overview of the
different types of numbers that you're
going to encounter on the act and
they're going to make mention of these
in the various problems so
as long as you're familiar with these
that'll make it a lot easier so i'll see
you in the next lesson